how do you approach a challenge I like
challenges you know one of the reasons I
love being a Jets fan is that they lose
a lot and and I'm much more into the
journey I look at challenges as the
narratives of my career right you know
whether this is egotistical or a nice
thing I'm not quite sure but I do think
of things in the body of my work you
know the book will be very boring if
everything's easy you know you need the
arc and so when I see challenges you
know I don't think that you get to have
the luxuries that come along with being
a leader or CEO or a founder if I've
want this if I want the attention if I
want the fruits of the things that come
along with it I have to be respectful
that the challenges come along with it
so when it when they come to me I really
kind of I'll paint you a picture I
genuinely love the scene in the movie
the cliche scene where the person gets
punched in the mouth you know turns
blood comes out spits out his tooth and
then looks back at the other person like
now what that's how I think about
challenges I really want I almost went
can I get weird with you per second I
even think sometimes I fabricate
challenges because I enjoy that more
than the easy sailing and so mom I think
any true purebred entrepreneur has the
stomach for challenges and so for me
it's just part of the equation
[Music]
[Music]